welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and marvel's moon knight just
dropped their first official trailer for
the six episode disney plus series
starring oscar isaac as mark spector a
man suffering from dissociative identity
disorder who moonlights as a vigilante
with lunar linked abilities from an
egyptian deity i mean ever since zombie
vision in one division i am here for
more supernatural heebie-jeebies
especially with doctor strange coming
back to scooby-doo this multiverse
madness so i'm gonna watch this trailer
react to it and then give you some first
thoughts before i break it down frame by
frame for all the easter eggs which i
will do in a separate video that will
come tomorrow and before we begin our
friends at short boxster giving away the
first moon night solo story marvel
spotlight 28 stick around to the end of
this video to learn how to enter to win
here we
go
hello and welcome to staying awake i
have a sleeping disorder
oh so he's steven right now
between my waking knives and dreams it
sounded like his accent even changed in
the middle of that line
oh smart
i got some kid cuddy in here all right
oh i'm gonna have to talk over this so
that it doesn't get flagged
oh it's a british museum not the same
museum as um
dane whitman
yeah she wants to she wants to bang
oh looks like he doesn't even know if
that experience is a dream or not whoa
so that was himself
oscar isaac is playing this part so well
he's the perfect casting for this
oh i like looping the audio that's
awesome
oh so cool i'm loving this
wow
oh man
ethan hawk is so creepy i've never seen
that side of him before
oh you see the ankh shadow
i love it
whoa he's hitting something now
that wasn't there before they added it
in
i am digging this let's
go
oh my god i'm so pumped for this okay so
just to give you an overview of what we
know about moon knight as a character
from the comics mark spector was the son
of a rabbi who trains as a boxer and
then becomes like a cia agent a u.s
marine a mercenary really and then
through his travels of egyptian ruins he
ends up getting possessed by the
egyptian moon deity of khonshu who gives
him these supernatural powers that are
really associated with the cycle of the
moon but the most popular depiction of
the character of moon knight really
explores his dissociative identity
disorder which looks like the direction
that they're taking with oscar isaac now
because originally just as a vigilante
he takes on these kind of alter egos the
wealthy one percenter of steven grant
and then the taxi driver jake lockley
but here it looks like they're mixing it
up a little bit steven grant is playing
an employee at the british museum in
london but i love how this trailer plays
with the chronology of it he seems like
a guy who's already kind of rattled so
even this guy doesn't even know when his
possession took place konchu is screwing
with his understanding of the sequence
of his own life the fact that this show
is embracing the horror side of the mcu
is something i'm very excited about that
was one of my favorite things from one
division none of us was quite sure how
much of wanda's sitcom reality was
really a hallucination or something
physically manifesting well imagine that
but in a show where we never really get
the answer to it because all of this is
being shown from his own mind he's never
really quite sure what his reality is or
who even is and as is the case with
people who suffer from dissociative
identity disorder they have no memory of
things that they did when their
conscious mind was being controlled by
one of the other identities we got to
talk about ethan hawk here he's playing
the villain of the series that he said
leading up to the show he was basing on
the cult leader david koresh leader of
the branch davidians waco texas he's the
one here who says there's chaos in you
and closed captioning reveals his
character name as arthur harrow now
arthur harrow was an obscure moon night
villain who really only shows up in one
issue i think that was 1985's deadly
knowledge moon knight volume 2 issue 2
dr arthur harrow is a renegade mad
scientist who suffers from a disease
that leaves him with a horrible facial
disfigurement he's working on a
scientific means to deaden the pain
centers of the human body he actually
based his work on nazi experiments world
war ii that had been outlawed by the
nuremberg trials he ends up rigging a
pyramid on the yucatan peninsula to try
to kill moon knight but he manages to
escape and it's revealed that he's
working for a secret organization known
as omnium that does not look to be the
case here though with a character it
might just be a name that they pulled
from the 80s comics and are now writing
a new version of the character who looks
very much like a kareshian cult leader
one of these free thinking enlightenment
figures leading a new way of life for
these poor poor people who flock to him
and i love how in this shot stephen
grant slash mark specter whichever
identity he is right now is the only one
left standing like he missed the cue for
when to bend the knee but i wonder if
the philosophy of the character from the
comics may still be the case for him now
he could be someone who's promising some
kind of freedom from pain freedom from
disease freedom from suffering both of
the mind and of the soul and that's why
people flock to him maybe people who are
terminally ill thinking that he might be
able to cure them of whatever their
ailment is so when he looks at mark
spector steven grant jake lockley
whoever he is here he may sense in him
that pain not suffering that chaos
perhaps even mark sought out this guy
looking for a cure looking for an answer
and this guy may have some knowledge of
magic and a cult in the mcu now in terms
of the role moon knight plays in the
marvel comics i don't want to offend any
moon knight fans here but the character
was designed to be marvel's batman in
the 80s he's a vigilante who goes back
and forth between a guy on the street
and a wealthy elite in a tower but the
difference in the marvel comics is that
really embraces the psychosis of the
character the ways that batman comics
don't normally do one possible
connection i'm excited to see is the
fact that steven works in the british
museum in london and as we just saw in
eternals cersei dane whitman work in a
museum just on the other side of the
city and eternals ended with a
post-credits scene that revealed dane
whitman as the black knight teaming up
with blade marshall ali's voice coming
in there so i am super excited for the
possibility of a possible knight team up
among these three characters in the city
dame whitman black knight blade and moon
knight all three of them connected
through this supernatural influence that
is now spreading throughout the mcu i
gotta say i love the song choice of kid
cuddies day and night talking about the
duality of these two times a day the
fact that moon knight can never truly
sleep he doesn't really know what time
of day what part of his life he's in how
he got to where he is toggling between
these different identities based off of
where the moon is in the sky and even
the song itself the way it is edited
starts to break down to where you can
never even get to the end of the song
just hold the phone hold the phone hold
the phone because this one phone call is
his one chance to connect with someone
else from the rest of his life to ground
him in one of his other identities i
also like the background of the phone is
an alligator looking gator confirmed but
really i just bring it up because as we
saw as he crept around the museum he did
pass that nile crocodile when he steps
forward but his reflection does not
follow probably the night he did get
possessed by konshu look i love these
kind of stories these kind of tv shows
because i get to break it down and find
little details little things hidden in
the visuals and reflections on surfaces
so i got a lot to break down in this i'm
gonna comb through this frame by frame
because i know there's all kind of cool
hidden details this is gonna be such a
fun show to break down weekly on the
channel well again my full in-depth
frame by frame analysis of this trailer
is gonna take some time so it's gonna
come out tomorrow i appreciate your
patience and another reminder that we
are partnering with shortbox to give
away a rated copy of marvel spotlight 28
the first solo moon night comic story
it's currently valued over 300 and that
value will only be going up as this
character gets more screen time on the
disney plus series short boxed is the
easiest and safest way to buy and sell
graded comic books you can download
short box for free on ios and android
they have an incredible selection of
graded comics they have everything from
recent favorites to the first
appearances of the x-men or spider-man
some of the most valuable comics in the
world all orders are fully protected and
insured for both buyers and sellers
thousands of the most respected dealers
and collectors in the industry trust
shortbox and use it every day to enter
this giveaway visit
shortbox.com new rockstars to enter and
to receive a promo code for 15 off your
first short boxed order again that's
shortbox.com
new rockstars in the meantime you can
support new rockstars by checking out
our merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter
follow me rockstars subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
[Music]
you